well it was i just started high schools
after i left primary school i was
playing professional chess yeah and like
bam i like
how i ended up in playing professional
chess was weird to begin with because i
never
like played it much i just liked video
games a lot yeah so
video it was the only video game that my
dad would play with me
like i remember i was playing at like
year three how old are you in year three
in the uk like eight
nine nine eight nine and the chess club
was only for like the last year which
was like all the 12 year olds yeah and i
remember
they wouldn't let me play with them but
one they let me play with them and this
is so anime right because yeah
because after outside of the chess club
i beat their best player in a game of
chess
right and then they're like no no you
gotta let this guy play with us he's
good yeah yeah
and so i beat them all and then i
nothing happened for like three years
until
it's my time to join the chess club and
i was like you have to join the church
right
yeah and then uh i was like i joined the
chess club
and uh our school had lost like every
single
chess tournament ever right because yeah
it was like a local i don't even know we
had this there was like a local circuit
right between all the schools played
each other like football and
every other sport right yeah there's one
for chess and uh
i remember that we started playing in
that and also
the guy who was uh number two in our
chess team because i was number one we
were both like equal
yeah which is also very anime right yeah
rival character and everything his power
levels are on par with mine
my whole chess like experience is
genuinely like an anime i'm gonna keep
talking and there's
more stuff to it yeah and then we just
started like
winning every single game like against
every other school like it wasn't even
close i remember like
these kids were bad and i remember every
time they were like
wait they would be like shocked at how
quickly we would beat these kids
yeah it's very different in professional
chess to playing at somebody doesn't
in professional chess it's it's a long
thing and i'll get more into it later
but
and these were games i could win in 20
minutes right like i could see how they
[ __ ] up and i would take it and i
to me it just made sense right i didn't
practice i was just good at games and it
made sense
and then one time there was a school and
these guys had been like number one
for like 10 years in a row or something
because they had a guy who was someone's
parent and
he's obsessed with chess knows like he's
very very good at chess
and we beat his team and they were like
shocked they were like
nanny you beat like the prodigy this is
like this is like a sports anime no this
is a [ __ ] sports anime you could base
a chess manga off of your life honestly
no right because i remember thinking
like it was weird because this guy was
making like a whole commercial bear in
mind i was like 12 right i don't know
what the [ __ ] was going on
and this guy was making like a whole
commotion he was like shocked and i was
sitting there and he was like walk me
through everything you did
and i was like uh i don't know i didn't
write it down because most you're
supposed to write it down yeah
national chess and he was writing it
down and i thought that was weird yeah
he was like why would you write down
your moves you did you just did them
yeah yeah
you're not gonna go back and he was like
which one which move why did you move
here how did you know how to do that and
stuff and i was like i don't know i just
like did it
yeah and then he spoke to my mom and was
like you should come to this thing and
it's like
it's like it's weird it's like 200 kids
come to a place
by the way chess for like kids is a
really weird kind of thing that's
it's really it's just adults pushing a
bunch of like cambridge kids
yeah yeah so i went to a location and
there was like two
300 kids all just playing chess then you
would get like an opponent and
if you want a lost you would then play
someone who was like
one yeah and the more you kept winning
the more you would go up and then
eventually people who won all their
games
go on to play for like the area yeah
like a legit tournament
legit okay here's the he's the best
hornet i was killing all my games right
yeah and i'd won like four
so you play seven i remember i won four
in a row they were really easy
my friend as well he'd lost like two and
then he was already out and i felt bad i
was like
i'll avenge you i'll avenge you i'll go
on for you i'll see you in the finals
and like it's weird because i never had
any like a lot of these kids as well
they would be studying it in between
games but i would just whip out like
pokemon and start playing it yeah
oh it's my time to go and save and play
but i remember i said like my fifth game
was against the guy i beat in my school
like the prodigy team whatever yeah and
i had to play him again and we and we
drew and i was really like
anti-climactic i was like [ __ ] i beat
him last time i wanted to beat him again
anyway i got on the team and i was okay
i was struggling because this is where
it was getting
really serious like uh i was decent
enough where i could win like 70 of my
games but it was still starting to get
like
really long because chess games never
went more than an hour yeah and then i
start becoming like two hours
yeah and i'm i'm i'm 13. i'm like this
is 10 to take them this is time
i just want to play [ __ ] pokemon but
i start winning and then
i got content they're like hey do you
want to play for your country and i was
like
sure i guess i'll play for my country
like why not yeah i'm doing good enough
so
i turn up i go to the first tournament
you won't believe
because i was number 10 so there's 10
seats right yeah one is the best 10's
the worst i was i was the worst on the
country
yeah uh was the country right yeah yeah
guess who was number one
i think i've told you guys this year
yeah yeah yeah it was like the main
bully at my school
you
who like no one knew he did this this is
the point in the manga where like the
flashback begins
like he used to bully me he was the main
rival
all along right he literally was the kid
that everyone was scared of and i
remember thinking like man he was really
good at halo wars too that was
that was weird right yeah and then then
suddenly like he's
really [ __ ] good at chess like he was
amazing and he was winning a lot against
like uh
like really really good players bear in
mind when it got to this point it was
pretty much
me him and eight kids who are going to
go to cambridge
you know what i mean the environment was
really weird as well and i remember just
that was when i really started to not
enjoy chess anymore
is that when i remember when i lost a
game i got [ __ ] bollocked by
the coaches they were furious at me
because they would take your sheet right
because this is when you had to start
writing it down yeah they would take
your sheet
and they would rinse you for your moves
yeah and then they would they would they
would
watch you the whole game so there's like
always an area above where they can
watch you yeah
like god and i remember if you made a
move that was under five minutes
that was a mistake you got [ __ ]
rinsed freaks they were like you didn't
you didn't think long enough wow you've
got to go through the options
because it gets to the point where
you're like you know that they're
thinking just as many moves ahead as
as you are yeah start to get really
difficult yes you're like
[ __ ] like i haven't studied enough at
this point because i i never studied
chess
but this is where i was getting to the
point where i was against people who
were naturally pretty good
but also were studying all the [ __ ]
time yeah right
and it's just a really bad environment i
really didn't like it it was just like
i was i would finish my games and i'd
play pokemon
they would want to talk about so why did
you move rock to you know f2
you know why did you do that dude it was
really impressive when he moved his i
was like i
don't we are playing chess for eight
hours today i do not want to talk about
jessica
it was just like a pretty just yeah it
was a really weird environment and
i i could i think if i came into chess
later in my life i would have had a more
healthy
enjoyment of chess yeah i still like to
play it occasionally but yeah i think
i'm just like scarred from
yeah the anime experience that i had
yeah because that's what's like that's
what i found
find so fascinating about chess is just
like like here like
talk talking to you hearing your chest
doing like hearing like reading up and
watching
what like magnus carson's i think that's
his name yeah
his story and then and how you were just
like you were just born and you just got
the game they're like
there are people who just studied the
game yeah and then they're just people
who just like a genius is it and they
don't know why yeah it's it's like it's
[ __ ] fast
it's [ __ ] fascinating it's it was
weird because you kind of
like no matter how good you are at
something and like how much raw talent
you have at something
when you start competing at such a high
level you start to realize that like
it doesn't matter as much but also you
meet people who also like
yeah you know there might be like 10
people in that country who also
have that same raw talent yeah right and
then it's like bach
yeah because then it starts to come to
like who can put them because i didn't
care about checks
i never cared about chess i was just
good at it and i just played it because
such a thing that a protagonist would
say
right i never cared about it where where
is the protagonist would have got to my
point
lost and then been like i'm going to
dedicate my life to jail i was like
pokemon ranger just came out yeah so
like
i'm i'm going to start spinning around
yeah you took the he cardinal go around
right where he's just like i lost the
end of the manga and it was it was just
kind of like
it gets to that point in your life we
all like i just i don't need this
anymore
and i and i remember my parents are so
sad because i mean i don't know why
my parents were so invested in it i
think that it was a mixture of proud and
also they loved bragging about it yeah
why wouldn't you do that yeah of course
your series got cancelled for
from from poor sales yeah yeah i had a
spin-off right so what happened is about
when i was like 15
16 or 17 i had like a rejuvenation of my
my enjoyment right do you remember a
website called uh
mlg game battles do you remember that i
remember that so it was where you could
like compete against cobb they all said
jiahu chess
and i remember i would compete against
like fully grown men and beat them on
yahoo chas they'd get so pissed off
and then i i joined the local pub and
that was a weird experience
yeah so i joined the local pub chess
team and i remember bear in mind they
were all like 80 to
40 year old men yes i remember one
one time i was playing against a guy who
looked like ross kemp
like the biggest like a skinhead
terrifying dude like
he's like this over the table like like
a brick [ __ ] out yeah yeah
like every every bouncer you see like at
a nightclub and i'm like
i'm like like 15 16 like this with my
coke and he had like a pint and like
smoking and i'm there with my coke like
occasionally checking my phone
i don't know if that pissed him off but
in between moves i wouldn't look at what
he was doing i would just check my phone
and i was like
because i'm normally thinking in my move
so i don't really pay much attention
and i remember when i beat him and he he
looked really [ __ ] angry and i was
so scared and i was like
is he going to hit me he looked he was
like this on the table like this
i can't believe i can't believe you won
i felt like you've done this
i can't believe you've done this people
people didn't like losing to a 15 year
old that happened a lot
yeah please cause like from a narrative
perspective there's so many interesting
ways you could tackle
just chess want to take like that
concept of like
you know your friend being beaten in the
preliminary
and then just cut to the scene where
you're like in the finals and your
friend is like that one guy who narrates
all your moves
he's like he's like he's a speedwagon
he's like he just did an on pass say
he's like what's going on
per se is when it just goes on with the
explanation
you know what the one okay this is going
to sound so nerdy there's one move in
chess that i always wanted to use
i don't know the name of it but it was
the one where like if someone moves
their
like pawn to and then like in front of
if you've moved your pawn too
yeah then they move it too as well that
you can then take it that's what
you'll say that's it i always wanted to
do that yeah dude
using a rook is uh a castling is op yeah
you always castle that's all i remember
like
it's like why did he castle there it's
like i'll tell you why
yeah i don't know because there's i
remember they tried to teach us they're
like why don't we use the indian prince
opening of 1970s
and i was like because they would when i
would do an opening move
i always did the same opening move
because i just liked it it was like nice
and symmetrical i liked it
and they were they would always say why
did you use the this person like yeah
like i said like the indian prince move
of 1764.
and i was like what the [ __ ] is that i
do i just i just like how the bishop
goes
bishop goes it just it just feels nice
you know i just feel like it's hard to
explain it when you're a kid because
you're just like you're just thinking
full moon's head and you're like if this
goes here and this goes here and this
goes here then you go that you know what
i mean
i just it's like any any sport i imagine
where
kids are really good at it yeah adults
are really pushy and
kind of like almost borderline some of
the kids i'd say they had like a
predatory relationship with it
yeah yeah because a lot of them again
like i said they they were
very rich parents whose kids went to
very good private schools
and they were destined to go to
cambridge or oxford no matter what and
they would you know exactly
what i mean what kind of kids i'm
talking about yeah when you spoke to
them you're like
we're from a different world that's
really awesome this is like their entire
world to them right yeah
yeah it was it was like something that
was forced upon them because it was
you know it's something that looks good
on the resume yeah
like yeah i mean too far it got me a few
good jobs or it helped a lot i remember
some job interviews
where they liked playing chess and they
would bring it up and it was like oh
that's cute you're good
it's like i don't know that's cute yeah
it was like yeah that's that's a really
you know i i think that's like a really
interesting story that you have
um yeah bottom line is we need to turn
this into an anime yeah yeah yeah
definitely if if someone was like i want
to like make a chess anime i would be
absolutely fine
just like talk talk to connor he has a
very interesting story this is this is
anyone likes would like
three stories because like it's just
it's the perfect
chance to like teach people about how to
play chess as well
i i think it's a really good game and
it's one of my favorite things to like
sit down and talk to someone about just
talk and then play chess yeah i think
it's a really good way to
i don't know just have fun exactly and
it's also fun beating people who think
they're good at channels
the power trip because i'll meet people
who have just been like studying chess i
mean it's getting really big on twitch
right now yeah exactly and you'll meet
people who are like
you know they're like really getting
into it yeah and you just like stomp
them
it's like oh well you cuz okay here's
the thing right here's the worst part
about chess professionally is that
you normally know like five or six moves
in if you've lost
or not but you have to play it for
another two and a half
hours and all it is yeah yeah right yeah
crappy that's the difference between
casual chassis and professional chairs
that casually you always think you could
win if you outsmart them professional
chess it's just like
how do i drag this out enough so that
maybe they'll make a mistake yeah yeah
and oh god yeah it sounds horrible it
was awful i hated it because it just got
to the point where it's like what's the
[ __ ] point in this
it's like being a troll online it's just
like i'm just i'm literally just being
awkward yeah you're just prolonging the
inevitable right yeah yeah and it's like
i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up 30 minutes in
and now i gotta put up with this for two
and a half years
it's it's like loading a game of league
and then five minutes in like your own
start
yeah so someone's hinting the jungle is
just afk are you like can i just can i
just can i just ff now yeah yeah can we
just ff
like it's this is like a diamond like a
diamond game right now like
no one's gonna make a mistake yeah
because i remember this you know i never
got praised for winning games they would
always be like good job you know when
they would praise me
when i made it [ __ ] hell for the
other person
i remember when i this poor girl i i
dragged it out and she made a mistake to
a stalemate
bear this game went on for like three
hours and 20 minutes or something
ridiculous
it was something [ __ ] long and i
remember i'd lost like an hour in 100
yeah and i just made it awkward i wasn't
playing the win anymore i was playing to
make it awkward for her
yeah and so i did things that you
wouldn't normally do to try and win you
would just do it to [ __ ] block
everything so annoy them right
yeah i remember she was getting so
stressed and i remember being like
this is kind of fun but also like i hate
this
and they when i taught you when i got
back it was like coming back into the
football locker room
nice one let's hit the shower son you
really made it hell for that 13 year old
girl congratulations
connor like i was just like man i didn't
feel good like i just lost i got a
stalemate like yeah yeah
i worked three hours for a stalemate
like are you kidding me
absolutely yeah dude there's other worst
ones there where like there was i
remember those people who would
constantly like because you can ask for
a draw
yeah like you want to draw and it would
[ __ ] my psychology up because i was like
does this mean i'm winning like i think
he's losing and one time i remember i i
regret it to this day i should have took
the draw and i lost
gave me an out that's the learning
experience man that's the character
development we need yeah exactly